promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur le secteur du jeu vidéo qui se
féminise selon le syndicat national du
jeu vidéo les femmes F il représente
désormais 24 % des salariés c'est 10
points de plus qu'il y a 10 ans une
femme sur 5 occupe même aujourd'hui un
poste de manager c'est deux fois mieux
qu'il y a 5 ans une féminisation qui
n'empêche pas malheureusement les
mauvaises pratiques le syndicat des
travailleurs du jeu vidéo dénonce par
exemple un secteur qui dévore
littéralement ses employés 22,5 %
auraient déjà traversé au moins une
période de crunch comprenait de périodes
de travail très intensees au cours de
l'année sans parler des affaires de de
harcèlement comme ce qui se passe
actuellement chez Ubisoft CIN anciens
cadres dont le numéro 2 du groupe ont
ainsi été placés en garde à vue après
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour
harcèlement sexuel institutionnel selon
le syndicat solidaire le harcèlement
moral et sexuel y est admis parce qu'il
est plus profitable pour l'entreprise de
maintenir des harceleurs en place que de
protéger ses employés fin de citation
voilà premix cité c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
Public
Sénat
promixité vous a été présenté par NG
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle